I think this is probably the most
important news of the day this is from
uh New York Post critics are bashing
star ballerina Misty Copeland who
started a petition to add more inclusive
shades of color to the traditional pink
Apple ballet shoe
Emoji Copeland 41 the first black woman
to PO to become a principal dancer at
the American Ballet Theater you probably
already knew that I know I did you hear
Misty copin you immediately know that
she's the first black woman to become a
principal dancer at the American Ballet
Theater if you didn't know now you do
uh but she posted about the the
initiative to her 1.8 million Instagram
followers so this is a petition she's
starting to get different shades of uh
the uh ballet shoe emoji on Apple it's
very important I think we have the video
of her talking about this petition do we
have it I think we do let's play that
for my entire 25- year career I have
pancaked my point shoes to match my skin
color until recently the only color
option for point shoes was European pink
I am so happy that several of the point
shoe brands have expanded to include a
wide range of flesh colored point shoes
that are more reflective of the variety
of skin color tones that dance ballet
that so there it is got this petition
going I don't know how many people have
signed it I think thousands have signed
it it's very important and this is
mostly this is mostly what we're used to
right people desperate to be victims
because of the Social Capital that comes
with it uh and also because it gives
their lives meaning uh you know feeling
victimized gives their lives meaning but
the demand for racism exceeds the supply
so they're stuck with complaining about
a lack of options with ballerina emojis
or whatever um but here here's the thing
we we live in a very safe and insulated
Society relatively speaking becoming
less safe all the time but still
generally safe generally
insulated generally prosperous also
becoming less prosperous
all the time but still
prosperous what we've discovered is
that people
who live in this kind of bubble and
don't have any underlying sense of
meaning in their lives because they
don't have faith um they don't have any
even real coherent
worldview uh they don't have purpose you
take those people you make them very
safe and comfortable um they get really
bored and they start to kind of
fetishize suffering and they come up
with all these kinds of uh sort of
luxury fears and concerns and they start
petitions over emojis and so on you know
you've heard me talk about how important
it is to have a VPN to protect your
online privacy but choosing a VPN you
trust it's equally as important I can
say with full confidence that expressvpn
is the best VPN on the market here's why
expressvpn doesn't log your on your
activity online you know lots of cheap
or free vpns they make money by selling
your data to advertisers but expressvpn
doesn't do this they even developed a
technology trusted server that makes
their VPN servers incapable of storing
any data at all expressvpn now uses
lightwe a new VPN protocol the engineer
to make user uh speeds faster than ever
expressvpn is so easy to use you don't
need any technical skills to get set up
just fire up the app and tap one button
to connect that's it even your
grandparents could do it even I can do
it if you can believe it and it's not
just me saying this Business Insider The
Verge and many other Tech journals rate
Express VPN the number one VPN in the
world protect yourself with the VPN that
I use trust at expressvpn.com slatwall
show use my Link at expressvpn.com
slatwall show to get three extra months
free that's exps vpn.com Walsh show and
this can only happen in our very
comfortable Western bubble but the
bubble is
not well it's it's not bulletproof
literally or figuratively and uh if it
ever pops
completely it's very disturbing to think
how unprepared we will be how shocked
and helpless I know I just said we
shouldn't live in fear and we shouldn't
but this is a reality that I see coming
in the future and it's just it's a it's
a very interesting contrast when you do
see war and death and
destruction uh happening right now but
not in this country and then you've got
people here worried about Balu
emojis and if ever these worlds really
do Collide and these realities do
Collide I think there's a lot of people
that are not going to be prepared for
that if you like to see what else I have
to say you can access my full show by
going to daily r.com or by going to the
Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to see
you there godp speed